Này trước dần tháng tạm, con phố thịt quý, hà nội, chở nên nắng nhật hơn bao giờ hứ?
Từ tháng sớm, giông dồi đáng lối dài trước thức tệ mánh trường thu chuyển thống,
dù phải tiếp hàng vài chụp, chơi dân vẫn kind nhận trở đổi,
đề mua được những chiếc mánh trường măng thương vị đổi thơ.
Đại mánh được trọn mua nhở, vẫn là mánh lướng và mánh đều nhìn thập cầm.
Kể đến là bánh đậu xanh, dần dưới, những vụ vị chuyển thống,
tắn bói với băng phế hệ người hà nội.
Nhiều khác mua số lượng lớn, đề vừa thường thức,
vừa làm quả biểu trong việc đết và nả viên.
Năm nay, dò sáng miếng lượng tăng, bánh lướng thập cầm tăng nhẹ từ nắm bánh lâm lình,
lên sống mình đồng trên chiếc, nhường sức mùa vẫn không tăng.
Chẳng lại, lượng khác cầm cầm cầm đông.